Schon vor 70 Jahren wurde dieser mysteriöse
Materiezustand in der Theorie vorhergesagt,
doch erst jetzt ist einem deutschen Forschungsteam
der eindeutige Beweis gelungen: Die Fachleute
aus Stuttgart konnten tatsächlich die Existenz
eines Suprafestkörpers nachweisen, bei dem
das Material - ACHTUNG - superflüssig und
fest zugleich ist.
What?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Diese Sache widerspricht total unseren Vorstellungen
von Aggregatzuständen, die man aus dem Alltag
kennt.
Im Klartext gemeint sind natürlich: fest,
flüssig oder gasförmig.
In der Physik kennt man aber noch weitere
Materie-Zustände: beispielsweise Plasma oder
Suprafluide.
Einem Forschungsteam aus Stuttgart ist jetzt
das gelungen, worauf Expertinnen und Experten
weltweit seit Jahren hinarbeiten: Die Rede
ist von dem Nachweis eines weiteren sehr exotischen
Materie-Zustandes.
Konkret geht es um den sogenannten Suprafestkörper.
Hierbei ist das Material flüssig und fest
zugleich.
Dafür sorgen Effekte aus der Quantenphysik:
Der suprafluide Zustand des Materials überlagert
sich hier mit dem festen.
Oder anders gesagt: Einzelne Atome sind entweder
Teil der Supraflüssigkeit oder aber Teil
des Kristalls - und das völlig unvorhersehbar.
Kurz zum Verständnis: Suprafluide sind Flüssigkeiten
oder Gase, die keine innere Reibung aufweisen.
Sie verfügen über keine Entropie und zudem
über eine unendlich hohe Wärmeleitfähigkeit.
Innerhalb eines solchen Stoffes kann also
kein Temperaturunterschied erzeugt werden.
Solche Suprafluide kommen im Kern von Neutronensternen
vor oder aber auch im ultrakalten Helium.
In ihrem Experiment arbeitete das Stuttgarter
Forschungsteam mit Dysprodium-Atomen, die
bis zum absoluten Nullpunkt bei minus 273
Grad Celsius heruntergekühlt wurden.
Die Atome wechselwirken dann auf zwei verschiedene
Art und Weisen: Zum einen stoßen sie zusammen,
wenn sich zwei Atome sehr nahe kommen.
Doch auch über eine längere Distanz können
sich diese Atome anziehen oder abstoßen.
Das liegt an den magnetischen Wechselwirkungen,
über die sie verfügen.
Das nutzte das Physik-Team aus und tarierte
die magnetischen Dipol-Wechselwirkungen so
aus, dass diese nicht nur eine Suprafluidität
ausbildeten, sondern zeitgleich auch eine
kristalline Gitterstruktur.
So entstand ein Suprafestkörper.
Dazu die beiden Physiker Mingyang Guo und
Fabian Böttcher, die an der Studie beteiligt
waren: “Die periodische Kristallbildung
konnten wir direkt optisch feststellen und
die quantenmechanische Überlagerung durch
Interferenzexperimente testen“.
Der endgültige Beweis für diesen Erfolg
gelang mit der Hilfe von Schallwellen.
Die Fachleute ließen diese mit zwei verschiedenen
Geschwindigkeiten durch den erschaffenen Suprafestkörper
laufen.
Da der Suprafestkörper ja zeitgleich fest
UND flüssig ist, konnte eine charakteristische
zweite Form von Schallwellen beobachtet werden.
Diese wies eine sehr geringe Geschwindigkeit
auf - eine Premiere und der endgültige Beweis
dafür, dass es sich bei der erzeugten Materie
tatsächlich um einen Suprafestkörper handelt.
Eine echte Premiere, denn obwohl dieser exotische
Zustand bereits in den 50er-Jahren vorhergesagt
wurde, konnte er bislang nicht zweifelsfrei
und eindeutig nachgewiesen werden.
Und so hatte sich in den vergangenen Jahren
ein echter Wettstreit zwischen Forschungsteams
weltweit entwickelt.
Die Stuttgarter Fachleute feiern ihr Ergebnis.
Dazu der Wissenschaftler Tilman Pfau: “In
diesem weltweiten Wettrennen ist es uns damit
zum ersten Mal gelungen, alle drei Bedingungen
für einen suprasoliden Zustand in einem Experiment
mit ultrakalten Dysprosium-Atomen zu demonstrieren“.
Superschwere Elemente – Die Jagd nach neuer
Materie.
Anklicken, anschauen und Doktor Whatson abonnieren!
Einer meiner absoluten Lieblingskanäle.
Bis dann bleibt dran.